Donald Trump has again commented on last night's
democratic presidential debate with a misspelled
attack on the various candidates this time
focusing his ire on Elizabeth Warren, referring
to her, uh, once again as Pocahontas, as well
as talking about Michael Bloomberg and Tom
Stier.
Tom Trump starting bright and early this morning
with the tweets saying quote, crazy, chaotic
Democrat debate last night.
Fake news said Biden.
Well even though he said half of our population
was shot to death would be over for most many
Mike was weakened, unsteady, but helped greatly
by his many commercials, which are not supposed
to be allowed during a debate.
Pocahontas was mean and undisciplined, mostly
aiming at crazy.
Bernie and Minnie Mike, they don't know how
to handle her, but I know she is a chocker.
Stier was a disaster.
Who along with many are setting records in
dollars per vote.
Just give me an opponent now does this Trump
mean that Warren is a choker and he misspelled
it or his Chalker sort of like Cobb FEFI a
word that Donald Trump according to at the
time, Sean Spicer that Trump knows what it
means and Trump's audience knows what it means
but I just am not in the know so I don't know
what it means that Warren is a Chalker Trump
also tweeting about the coronavirus and we
are very quickly learning and this is, this
is really scary stuff.
We are quickly learning how unprepared this
administration is to deal with Corona virus
having all sorts of people and important medical
positions and positions related to public
health that are interim people reducing funding
to many of the key agencies that would be
dealing with something like a Corona virus
pandemic.
This is a real crisis which we are going to
be talking about in more detail.
If the administration doesn't get prepared
for Corona virus, people will die who didn't
have to die.
And Trump is making it all a political game
saying quote, low ratings, fake news.
Ms DNC, Comcast and CNN are doing everything
possible to make the Corona virus look as
bad as possible, including panicking markets
if possible.
Likewise, they're incompetent.
Do nothing.
Democrat comrades are all talk.
No action.
USA in great shape.
I will be having a news conference at the
white house on this subject today at 6:00
PM CDC representatives and others will be
there.
Thank you.
Now we are not in great shape and this is
not political for me.
I want to be in great shape no matter who
the president is.
Just because it's not a pandemic now doesn't
mean it won't become one, but Trump only cares
about appearances.
How does he look at the Corona virus context?
Uh, and, and think about it.
It's how did Obama do with Ebola versus how
am I doing with Corona virus?
It's optics.
What kind of statements that Obama Bay make
versus what Trump is doing?
This is sport for Trump.
It's Trump, Corona virus versus Obama, Ebola.
That's all it is and that doesn't keep you
safe.
It doesn't keep me safe.
Trump then also tweeting this morning just
landed India was great trip, very successful
heading to the white house meetings and calls
scheduled today.
CDC and secretary is our and all doing a great
job with respect to Corona virus briefing
this afternoon.
Now of course if you watched our coverage
yesterday of Trump's trip to India, you know
that it was yet another embarrassment for
Donald Trump from showing up at a huge rally
of 100,000 Indian people mispronouncing half
of his speech while looking at the teleprompter,
the way your dog looks at a speaker that's
playing a recording of your voice and meanwhile
half the crowd as we showed you video of yesterday
was fleeing to the exits while Donald Trump
was speaking, followed by a press conference
in India during which Trump said that Ruth
Bader Ginsburg and Sonia Sotomayor should
recuse themselves from any Supreme court case
even tangentially related to Trump or his
administration.
We are living in Idiocracy.
It was not a great trip to India.
And we are unfortunately it's happening to
me too.
We are desensitized to it a little bit more
every day.
So we'd better get resensitized to it and
pretty quickly or we are going to be very
distraught at the results on November 3rd
and we will end up with another four years
of this atrocity.
We will of course see what it is that Donald
Trump says is that at that 6:00 PM Eastern
time Corona virus briefing today.
Uh, but we are actually going to be speaking
to a doctor specializing in infectious disease
about what is going on with Corona virus,
who this may not come as a shock to, you know,
a lot more than what Donald Trump has been
able to glean from the highly partisan media
that he consumes on a daily basis.